[Music]
[Applause]
if I told you about a network that
stretches the equivalent of 30 times
around the earth with 600 cross-connect
switches and yet was owned by a city
council you'd probably think it was time
I hung up this microphone and called it
a day but it's quite true it's owned by
Stockholm City Council it's called Stoke
up and its CEO Stephan in verson is
sitting right beside me Stefan it sounds
an incredible network and it started way
back in 1994 yes that's true
Thank You Bryan thank you for for having
me here and being able to talk a bit
about still cab yeah almost 25 years now
and we've been building a multi fibre
point-to-point network since since then
I think we've invested about 500 million
euros for the last 24 years into the
network all on earnings and loans so
we're we're unlike a private company
although we're owned by the city and
what we do is to provide dark fiber for
everybody wants to to lease it and
that's what we've been doing from the
start and that's what we are doing
looking forward so what is not enabled
what it has enabled is that we have
today in my network over 900 customers
100 service providers and operators you
can lease a fiber pair if you want you
can start with your two empty hands or
like an empty fiber parrot so to speak
so we have a multitude of SMEs coming
out in the Stockholm tech environment
that uses this network we have of course
a fierce competition looking at the
delivery to the businesses and
households so we have very low prices
you can get I think the lowest I've seen
as you can get one gigabit synchron for
us low as about 20 euros a month
cranky and I guess really what you've
set up makes you ideally place for
things like you know 5g IOT all these
things that are going to descend upon us
well we hope so we have I think we have
created a level playing field who
created a market for the players that
are there today and what we aim to do is
to bring that market also to the world
of IOT and 5g we have today for 4G LTE
players in stockholm stockholm is not
that big it's about 1 million
inhabitants and i see it is a great
possibility for the 5g players coming in
to establish themselves on the stock
market because they will not be making
make him that he used the share
investments that I have done to provide
their services in the future okay well
thank you for talking to us you so
Stockholm the city in Europe for 5g and
IOT
[Music]
you